Headshot parents, if you didn't notice it in the title, our topic today is book the jobs that bleep you just heard, it won't be in the rest of the episode. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. Many of us at some point in our careers have had jobs that seem pointless. I once had a bullshit job working as a work study student when I was in college. I passed out flyers for the street car during one summer. I could not figure out why I was doing it.
听众朋友们，如果你们没在标题里注意到的话，我们今天的话题是那些哔——的工作（这里听到的哔——声在接下来的节目中不会再出现了）。
I've had some temp jobs where I've literally sat in the closet. Jobs where you ask yourself, what am I even doing here? Like really, what is my actual role at this company? If I disappear tomorrow, would anyone notice? I was doing some paper filing, but they didn't have that much paper filing and for a week I sat in a supply closet. Doing expense reports and creating a new piece of paper for every single transaction item
我做过一些临时工，真的就是坐在杂货间里。那些会让你自问“我到底在这里干什么？”的工作。就像真的在想，我在这家公司的实际角色到底是什么？如果我明天消失了，会有人注意到吗？
on every receipt for every single thing that expense like down to like the most minimal thing. This week we're looking at jobs that feel so pointless, so gut wrenchingly boring, that they are in the words of one expert, Bulschen. If you don't have one of these jobs yourself, you probably know someone who does. Like the guy binging YouTube videos on his computer at work, or the woman who always seems to be playing solitaire. So it was almost all office workers, almost all people who had jobs where, you know,
每个收据上的每个交易项目，甚至精细到最微小的事情，都要做费用报销报告，还要为每一笔开销单独做一张纸。本周我们探讨的这些工作，感觉如此毫无意义，无聊得让人痛心疾首，用一位专家的话来说，就是“扯淡的工作”。
you kind of see them there and you kind of wonder, is that kind of really doing anything? Well, it turns out, you know, they're not. Why do these jobs exist? Why do they seem to be proliferating? And what effects do these jobs have on us? The American TV show The Office tells the story of a paper supply company in Pennsylvania. People show up at work, but it's not always clear what they're doing.
如果你自己没有这种工作，你可能也认识这样的人。比如那个在上班时用电脑疯狂刷YouTube视频的家伙，或者那个似乎总是在玩纸牌游戏的女士。所以这几乎全是办公室职员，几乎所有人都在做这样一种工作，你知道的，
A lot of the time, people invent pranks or distractions. You put my stuff in jello again. They're bored. Many of them want to find meaning in their work, but what they are doing is pointless. You want me to write down people's indefinable qualities. I want you to write down everything that people are doing all day and then type it up in a way that is helpful. Michael Scott, the boss played by Steve Corral, leads the way. I don't want to work. I just want to bang down this bungalow today. Did you ask me here for any specific reason? the way. David Graber has spent quite a bit of time thinking about the many, many real-life
你看着他们坐在那儿，然后心里就会犯嘀咕：那家伙真的在干什么吗？好吧，事实证明，你知道的，他们确实什么都没干。为什么会有这些工作？为什么这些工作似乎在激增？这些工作对我们有什么影响？美国电视剧《办公室》讲述了宾夕法尼亚州一家纸品公司的故事。人们按时上班，但他们到底在干什么并不总是那么清楚。
versions of Michael Scott. He's a professor of anthropology at the London School of Economics and he's the author of the book, Bulsha Jobs, a theory. David, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, thank you. So you wrote this essay a couple of years ago that has now turned into a book and you described an entire category of jobs. You call these bullshit jobs and they're not necessarily menial jobs or boring jobs, but they're almost always pointless jobs. Yes, they're actually quite rarely menial. I mean, there are some cases where people say hired as a museum garden told to guard a room of nothing in it. That would be both menial and boring. But most often these jobs are, if nothing else, prestigious and well-paid.
大卫·格雷伯花了不少时间思考迈克尔·斯科特的众多现实版本。他是伦敦政治经济学院的人类学教授，也是《扯淡的工作：一种理论》一书的作者。大卫，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。哦，谢谢。所以你几年前写过一篇文章，现在已经变成了一本书，你在书中描述了一类完整的工作。
A lot of jobs like this are in middle management, they're clerical, managerial, administrative sort of positions, or their positions in PR, marketing, human resources, almost invariably, they are well paid, with good benefits, and he got a lot of prestige, yet at the same time the people who do them are often report themselves genuinely miserable. They feel they're living a lie, and not only that, they're living a lie against their will. They'd really rather be doing something useful with their lives. So when you wrote this essay a couple of years ago, I'm not quite sure you anticipated this,
很多这样的工作都在中层管理、文书、管理、行政类职位，或者是公关、市场营销、人力资源等职位，几乎毫无例外，它们的薪水很高，福利很好，而且享有很高的声望，然而与此同时，从事这些工作的人往往觉得自己非常痛苦。
but the response to the essay was extraordinary. People wrote in from all over the world saying, help, I'm stuck in a BS job. Yeah, I mean all over the world, people seem to recognize themselves in the story I told. And the story I told was almost a joke. You go to these parties and you talk to people who are married to academics or you know in the business world and so what do you do and often to sail nothing really? And you know at first they thought they're just being modest or don't think their job was very interesting but you know apply them over a few drinks and eventually they will often admit that they meant it literally. They literally do nothing. So I wrote in this little piece where I basically said, well, you know, back in the 30s, they thought we'd be working
但这篇文章的反响非同寻常。来自世界各地的人们写信来说：救命，我被困在一份扯淡的工作里了。是的，我是说世界各地的人们似乎都在我讲述的故事中看到了自己的影子。
a 15-hour week by now. They thought that, you know, mechanization would mean we'd be living lives of leisure, but instead of just, you know, decreasing the working week, what they seem to have done is just made up these imaginary jobs to keep us all busy. It's almost as if there's some fiendish intelligence making up a pointless position for us to do. How did this happen? And I wrote this piece, and it just went crazy.
他们本以为，你知道的，机械化意味着我们将过上悠闲的生活，但他们似乎并没有缩短每周的工作时间，而是编造了这些虚构的工作来让我们所有人都有事可做。这就好像有什么邪恶的智慧在为我们编造一个毫无意义的职位来做这一切。这一切是怎么发生的？我写了这篇文章，然后它就火了。
I really didn't anticipate anything like it. I mean, all over the world, people were translating it, distributing it, server-kept, crashing. Then they put it in newspapers, would run it as a column, and you get these comment sections, which are just amazing. People would say things like, oh my god, it's true. I'm a corporate lawyer, I contribute nothing to humanity, I'm just miserable all the time. Confession started pouring out, so I realized this was a much larger phenomenon than I'd even imagined. I understand that polls have been conducted asking people, do you think your job is meaningless, do you think your job is pointless? What do they tell us? Well, yeah, that actually surprised me, even after the outpouring on the internet, I thought, okay, you know, maybe 15, 20% of jobs are like this. And remember, these are people who think their own jobs are pointless. I mean, I'm not going to go and
我真的没有预料到会有这样的反响。我是说，世界各地的人都在翻译它、传播它，服务器都崩溃了。然后他们把它放进报纸里，当作专栏发表，你会看到那些评论区，简直太棒了。人们会说这样的话：哦，天哪，这是真的。我是一名公司律师，我对人类没有任何贡献，我只是整天都很痛苦。
tell somebody who feels his job is meaningful that they're wrong, but, you know, if you feel you're not doing everything all day, who would know better than you. All right, so after a while, they conducted us some surveys. And one of them was you go. And then later, they did another one in Holland. And they both came up with pretty much exactly the same results between 37 to 40% of all people who had jobs were convinced that if their job didn't exist, it would make no difference at all. That is a huge number, David. It's insane. I had no idea. And that's the people who are sure of it. You know, only 50%
好吧，后来他们做了一些调查。其中一个是YouGov。后来，他们在荷兰又做了一次。他们得出的结果几乎完全一样：所有有工作的人当中，有37%到40%的人确信，如果他们的工作不存在，将不会产生任何影响。这是一个巨大的数字，大卫。这太疯狂了。我根本不知道。
of people were sure their jobs made a difference, absolutely. And if you think about all the types of jobs, or no one would possibly doubt that they're fulfilling a useful social function, I mean, you know, I'm sure the number of bus drivers, the number of nurses, the number of mechanics and repairmen, also service workers, actually. You know, I eventually asked people to send in testimonies and stories about their most pointless jobs, and almost none of them were in service or retail. It was almost all office workers, almost all people who had jobs where you see them there and
如果你想想所有那些没有人会怀疑它们正在履行有用的社会职能的工作类型，我的意思是，你知道的，我确信公交车司机的数量、护士的数量、机械师和修理工的数量，实际上还有服务业工人的数量。你知道的，我最终请人们发送关于他们最无意义工作的证词和故事，几乎没有一个是在服务业或零售业。
you wonder, is that really doing anything? Well, it turns out they're not. David in your book, you described the story of Kurt Kurt who's a German military subcontractor and he feels his job is utterly pointless. Why does he feel this way? Yes, this is one of the first really elaborate examples I got of the kind of job I was talking about given to me spontaneously by someone on the web. Said, I'm a subcontractor to a subcontractor to a subcontractor, all private firms who work for the German military.
大卫，在你的书中，你描述了库尔特的故事，库尔特是一名德国军事分包商，他觉得自己的工作毫无意义。他为什么会有这种感觉？是的，这是我在网络上由某人自发给我的、关于我所讨论的那类工作的最早、最详细的例子之一。他说：我是德国军方雇用的私人公司的分包商的分包商的分包商。
And he said, you know, because of outsourcing, if a German soldier wants to move his desktop computer from one office to another, he actually has to fill out a bunch of forms He calls human resources they call logistics they call meat Quart, they mustn't even compute our own sterren, but schner And I have to drive 500 kilometers sometimes if a rented car drive to wherever this military base is Fill out a raft of forms put the thing in a box goes down the hall. Somebody else takes out of the box,
他说，你知道的，因为外包，如果一个德国士兵想把他的台式电脑从一个办公室搬到另一个办公室，他实际上必须填写一堆表格。他打电话给人力资源部门，他们打电话给后勤部门，他们打电话给肉类四分之一（Meat Quart），他们甚至不会计算我们的斯特伦，但施纳，
gives me another form to sign, and then I drive home. And that's his entire job. And one of the interesting things about these jobs is that people were often very confused about how much people knew and how much they could admit. Does my supervisor know that I spend most of the day actually making cat memes? Do they know I'm playing computer games? Am I allowed to say to what degree do my co-workers know? Can I tell them? There's all these questions that people have. How much do I have to pretend to work? And how
而我有时必须开车500公里，如果租一辆车，开到这个军事基地的任何地方，填写一大堆表格，把东西放进盒子里，拿到大厅去。另一个人把东西从盒子里拿出来，
much am I just allowed to be seen to be just kicking back? And people are very nervous about this. There are all these gray zones. They'll hire someone an engineer in case the air conditioners break. For some reason, they find it impossible to just say, well, you're just here in case the air conditioners break. Otherwise, try to keep the people out of people's way and let them, you know, the internet or do whatever they like all day. Somehow that's not allowed. So they have to make up these rituals, or at the very least you have to pretend to be working because it's considered somehow insulting not to.
给我另一份要签名的表格，然后我开车回家。这就是他的全部工作。关于这些工作，有趣的事情之一是，人们常常对人们知道多少以及他们能承认多少感到非常困惑。我的主管知道我把一天的大部分时间都花在制作猫咪表情包上了吗？他们知道我在玩电脑游戏吗？
Often people really suffered from that. The fact that A, they had to pretend to some degree. They couldn't just pursue their own projects. And B, they're never quite sure how much they were allowed to pretend. This actually leads us to a story that you describe about your own life. You and some friends signed up to be dishwasher. And something happened on the job. Right. Something happened on the job that made you think about the role of time in how work is constructed. Tell me that story.
人们确实因此而饱受折磨。事实是，A，他们在某种程度上必须假装。他们不能只去追求自己的项目。B，他们从来不确定自己被允许假装到什么程度。这实际上让我们想到了你描述的关于你自己的生活的一个故事。你和一些朋友报名去洗碗。工作时发生了一件事。
Okay, this is the very first job I had. I think I was 14 years old, maybe 15. And it was at a beach resort. And I got a job working as a dishwasher in the kitchen. And it was a whole bunch of us who were hired at the same time, we're all about 15 years years old and being 15 year old boys, you know, when the big rush came we took it on as a challenge. We were like, okay, we are going to be the very best dishwashers of all time, you know.
好吧，这是我拥有的第一份工作。我想我当时14岁，也许15岁。那是在一个海滩度假村。我得到了一份在厨房当洗碗工的工作。我们是一群同时被雇用的人，我们大约都是15岁，作为15岁的男孩，你知道的，当大批客人涌来时，我们把它当作一项挑战。
We're going to be so fast, we're going to be so efficient, the bus is going to be really impressive. You know, we went at it and we like finished it in record time, had this huge, sparkling pile of dishes and kind of kick back. ["The Best of Us"] Boss came in, showing off our handy work, and he was like, what the hell are you guys sitting around for? He said, well, we just finished all the dishes.
我们全力以赴，就像在创纪录的时间内完成了工作，堆起了一大堆闪闪发光的盘子，然后放松下来。老板走进来，向我们展示我们的手艺，他说：你们这群人坐在这里到底在干什么？他说：嗯，我们刚洗完所有的盘子。
And he said, yeah, well, keep working, you're on my time. You're not, you know, you can lounge around on your own time. And we're like, what do you mean? And I mean, you know, there's nothing to do. And he said, well, clean the baseboards. And said, well, we already clean the baseboards. So to clean them again.
他说：是啊，好吧，继续工作，你在拿着我的工资。你不能，你知道的，你可以在你自己的时间闲逛。我们就像是：你是什么意思？我的意思是，你知道的，没什么可做的。他说：好吧，清理踢脚板。并说：好吧，我们已经清理过踢脚板了。那就再清理一遍。
So we realize that there is this kind of weird idea that there is like my time in your time. If I have paid you money, I own your time. And you're not allowed to just kick back. You're not allowed to, you know, there's no point in working fast. That's what we've basically learned. Don't be too efficient because then they'll just make up work and that that
所以我们意识到，有一种奇怪的观念，认为有“我的时间”和“你的时间”之分。如果我付给你钱，我就拥有你的时间。你不被允许只是放松。你不被允许，你知道的，快速工作是没有意义的。这就是我们基本上学到的东西。不要太高效，因为那样他们只会凭空造出工作来，而那
Experience of doing work that you know is a necessary just because the boss doesn't want to see you being idle is really degrading and it got me to thinking, this concept of my time. How can your time belong to someone else? How can you rent time? And I started doing a little research, and I realized, not at the time, but since, that this is a really weird concept that just never would have occurred to most people who've ever lived.
种做你知道是不必要的工作的体验，仅仅因为老板不想看到你无所事事，真的是非常贬低的，这让我开始思考，“我的时间”这个概念。你的时间怎么会属于别人呢？你怎么能租用时间呢？我开始做一些研究，我意识到，不是在当时，而是从那以后，这真的是一个非常奇怪的概念，对于曾经生活过的大多数人来说，这绝对是想都不会想到的。
And in the ancient world, if you see a potter, if you're an ancient Roman or an ancient world, if you see a potter, if you're an ancient Roman, or an ancient Greek, you could see a potter and you could imagine buying the pot, that's easy, right? You could imagine buying the potter, they had slavery, but the idea that you could rent this potter's time was just bizarre, it just never would have occurred to anybody. It takes a whole series of very complicated philosophical and also technological changes that make it possible to take time, make it into uniform units that can then therefore be bought and sold.
在古代世界，如果你看到一个陶工，如果你是一个古罗马人或古代世界的人，如果你看到一个陶工，如果你是一个古罗马人或古希腊人，你可以看到一个陶工，你可以想象买下这个陶工，这很简单，对吧？你可以想象买下这个陶工，他们有奴隶，但是你可以租用这个陶工的时间的想法简直太离谱了，这是任何人绝对都不会想到的。这需要一系列非常复杂的哲学和技术变革，才能把时间变成统一的单位，从而可以买卖。
You teach at the London School of Economics, but before that you worked at Yale University, in your book, David, you point out that the cost of education has skyrocketed in many parts of the world. The reason isn't that teachers are being paid more than they were before. Instead you say universities have gone out and hired an army of workers who are doing BS jobs. Yeah, this is actually really market in America and America I have the statistics. The number of administrators has gone up quite sharply, much more so than teachers.
你在伦敦政治经济学院教书，但在那之前你在耶鲁大学工作过，大卫，你在书中指出，世界许多地方的教育成本已经飙升。原因并不是教师的薪水比以前高了。相反，你认为大学走出去雇佣了一支从事扯淡工作的工人军队。是的，这在美利坚实际上非常明显，美国我有统计数据。行政人员的数量急剧上升，远超教师。
But even more important than that, the number of administrative staff has just skyrocketed. It's like 240% increase over the last 30 years. So administrative staff basically mean all those guys who work for the deans, for the vice provost, all these endless positions are constantly making up. And what seems to be going on is that these people are being hired essentially for little reason other than making the people now running the universities who are no longer the teachers no longer the professors, but rather top administrators. Basically feel good about themselves, feel important.
但比这更重要的是，行政人员的数量简直呈火箭般上升。在过去的30年里，大约增长了240%。因此，行政人员基本上意味着所有那些为院长、副教务长工作的人，所有这些不断被编造出来的无休止的职位。而且情况似乎是，这些人被雇用的原因基本上除了让现在管理大学的人感到自我良好、觉得自己很重要之外，没有别的理由。
They hire these guys who are basically there, almost like feudal retainers. You know, I get hired as a vice provost. So obviously I need four or five assistants. You know, they decide what the assistants will actually do later. Systems trying to figure out something to do. So these are the assistants I know. I'll fill out, you know, I'll do a time allocation study. And then suddenly people like me have to spend hours of every week filling out time allocation
他们雇佣这些人，基本上就像封建随从一样。你知道的，我被聘为副教务长。所以很明显我需要四五个助理。你知道的，他们决定助理以后实际上要做什么。助理试图想出点事情做。所以这些是我知道的助理。我将填写，你知道的，我将做一项时间分配研究。然后突然像我这样的人每周不得不花几个小时填写时间分配
studies breaking down exactly what I do every hour of the day. So I can't actually do stuff as I'm filling out the forms. And this is how it works. Like the more of these guys there are in these bullshit jobs, the less time the people with real jobs have to actually do their work. And this isn't just universities. I mean, the same things happening in hospitals. More and more hospital administrators
研究，详细说明我在一天中的每一个小时都在做什么。所以我实际上无法在填写表格的同时做事情。这就是它的运作方式。就像这些从事扯淡工作的人越多，拥有真正工作的人实际做工作的时间就越少。这不仅限于大学。我的意思是，医院里也发生了同样的事情。越来越多的医院行政人员
means nurses have to spend more and more time doing paperwork and less time nursing. Primary school, same thing. Teachers just have to spend all their time in meetings and reports. Okay, by this point you might be looking around at fellow commuters, at co-workers, at friends, and asking yourself which people find their work boring and pointless. It turns out there are tales to identify people doing bullshit jobs. Stay with us.
意味着护士必须花越来越多时间做文书工作，而花在护理上的时间更少了。小学，情况也是如此。教师不得不把所有时间都花在会议和报告上。好吧，到这个时候，你可能会环顾四周的通勤者、同事、朋友，问自己哪些人觉得他们的工作既无聊又毫无意义。事实证明，有一些方法可以识别从事扯淡工作的人。请继续收听。
Working a bullshit job might feel like an exercise in futility, a task that seems completely pointless. In truth, there's a perverse logic that shapes how and why these jobs come to be. David Graber has brought an anthropologist's eye to the life of the board office worker, and he's come up with a classification system for different kinds of BS jobs. The first category is something he calls a duct taper.
做一份扯淡的工作可能会让人感觉像是一场徒劳的练习，一项似乎完全没有意义的任务。事实上，有一种反常的逻辑塑造了这些工作如何以及为什么会产生。大卫·格雷伯将人类学家的视角带入了死板的办公室职员的生活中，他为各种不同类型的扯淡工作提出了一套分类系统。第一类是他所谓的“胶带工”。
Rather than fix serious headaches, many organizations take the easy route. They paper over the problem. David has a revealing story from his own life. This was quite early on in my time in the UK university system. And they had this shelf in my office. I was always a little worried about it. It seemed kind of precarious. And one day it was completely ripped out of the wall. There was this huge gaping hole in the wall.
许多组织并没有解决严重的棘手问题，而是选择了捷径。他们掩盖了问题。大卫有一个来自他自己生活的揭示性故事。这发生在我进入英国大学系统初期。我的办公室里有这样一个书架。我总是有点担心它。它看起来有点摇摇欲坠。有一天，它完全从墙上被扯了下来。墙上有一个巨大的大洞，
There was kind of mangled metal hanging over my desk. So obviously in a way I could fix it myself. And so I called buildings and grounds. And they said, OK, we'll send a carpenter. And it took about a week and a half for the carpenter to show up and people in the office were calling I was calling everybody was calling and it became this daily ritual and I gradually realized there's one guy we always got the same guy whose entire job seemed to consist of apologizing for the fact that the carpenter was very busy and couldn't come. And one day it occurred to me like, well, why don't they just fire that guy and hire a second
有扭曲的金属挂在我的办公桌上方。所以很明显，某种程度上我可以自己修复它。于是我打电话给建筑和地面维护部门。他们说，好吧，我们会派一个木匠来。木匠出现花了一个半星期的时间，办公室里的人都在打电话，我当时也在打电话，每个人都在打电话，这成了一种日常仪式，我渐渐意识到有一个家伙——我们总是找同一个人——他的全部工作似乎就是为木匠很忙而且不能来这一事实道歉。有一天我突然想到：好吧，他们为什么不解雇那个家伙，雇一个第二个
carpenter? He'll be, then he won't need him, right? And I mentioned this to various people and they looked at me like, yeah, right, that would ever happen. And I realized that this is a perfect example of a bolted job. His job is only necessitated because the system is stupidly constructed. So he's there to see equivalent of if you had a leak
木匠呢？那样的话，他们就不需要他了，对吧？我向不同的人提起了这件事，他们看着我的表情就像是：是啊，对，那会发生才怪。我意识到这是扯淡工作的完美例子。他的工作之所以必不可少，仅仅是因为这个系统建得太蠢了。所以他在那里，这就相当于如果你的屋顶漏水了，
in the roof, instead of fixing the roof, you hire some guy to empty a bucket every hour. It's a totally pointless position. And gradually, I realized that in the software industry industry at least this is called duct taping. I want to talk about a second category of Bush's job, David. This one involves managers who come up with meaningless assignments for their subordinates. You called them taskmasters? That's right. Now a taskmaster is a type of bullshit job which involves one,
你不是去修屋顶，而是雇一个人每小时倒一次桶。这是一个完全没有意义的职位。渐渐地，我意识到在软件行业，至少在软件行业，这被称为打补丁（胶带固定）。我想谈谈第二类扯淡的工作，大卫。这一类涉及为下属想出毫无意义的任务的经理。你称他们为主管任务的人（Taskmasters）？没错。现在，任务主管是一种扯淡的工作，它涉及第一，
there's two different types actually. One of them is simply a supervisor of people who don't need supervision. And a lot of middle managers wrote to me and said that they had that kind of job. Often they'd done a certain job, they got promoted to management, so they knew what was entailed doing the job, and they knew that basically they didn't need supervision at all, but they had to pretend they were supervising them anyway. But another type is exactly what I was describing in the case of universities. People whose job seems to end up being creating paperwork and unnecessary tasks for other people to do. So again, to go back to the middle management example, say you did have a job and you got
其实有两种不同的类型。其中之一很简单，就是不需要监督的人的监督者。许多中层经理写信给我，说他们有那种工作。通常他们做过某项工作，然后被提升到管理层，所以他们知道这份工作包含什么，并且他们知道基本上他们根本不需要监督，但他们还是得假装在监督他们。但另一种类型正是我在大学案例中所描述的那种。那些工作似乎最终变成了为其他人创造文书工作和不必要的任务的人。因此，再次回到中层管理人员的例子，假设你有一份工作，你得到了
promoted to supervising that job and you knew that they didn't need supervision. Gradually, you would realize that rather than to sit here all day, probably the best thing you could do to make look good to your boss is to create some kind of target system. Give them paperwork to do to make sure they're hitting their targets and then there'll be something to file in process and you'll have something that you can do. The classic example comes from the story of a woman named Chloe. She was one of the few people who was in academic administration in the higher echelons who was willing to
晋升去监督那份工作，你知道他们不需要监督。渐渐地，你会意识到，与其整天坐在这里，你能在老板面前表现得好的最好方法可能是建立某种目标系统。给他们一些文书工作去做，以确保他们达到了目标，然后就会有东西可以存档和处理，你就会有事情可做了。最经典的例子来自一个名叫克洛伊的女性的故事。她是高层学术行政人员中为数不多的愿意站出来向我承认这一点的人之一。
come forward and admit this to me. She said, well, you know, I took on this job as a non-executive dean. She says non-executive basically means you have no power, you don't control money. So you're strategic. You're supposed to come up with ideas, but you have no real ability to make anybody do that. So essentially she had a pointless job, she would come up with a plan and then nobody would pay any attention. However, she was given three assistants again. That's what happens. As soon as you get a prestigious position, they immediately give you assistance and then you have to figure out something for them to do. In her case, none of them had any obvious function, so she had to spend her time making up things for them to do so they wouldn't get in trouble for just sitting around.
她说：好吧，你知道的，我接受了非执行院长这份工作。她说非执行基本上意味着你没有权力，你不控制金钱。所以你是战略性的。你应该想出点子，但你没有真正的能力让任何人照办。所以本质上她有一份毫无意义的工作，她会想出一个计划，然后没有人会去理睬它。然而，她又被分配了三个助理。事情就是这样。一旦你得到了一个享有声望的职位，他们就会立刻给你分配助理，然后你必须想办法给他们找点事做。在她的情况下，他们都没有任何明显的功能，所以她不得不把时间花在编造事情让他们做上，这样他们就不会因为无所事事而惹上麻烦。
So you can have BS jobs to help the boss feel like he's actually necessary when he isn't. You can have BS jobs that are designed to paper over problems that an organization cannot or does not want to fix. David also describes a third type of BS job. On the surface, these jobs are not pointless, but the only reason an organization has them is because other organizations have them. David calls the people who work these jobs goons. I asked him what he meant by the term. I had to make that up because so many people
所以你可以拥有扯淡的工作，来帮助老板觉得他实际上是必要的，而他其实并不必要。你可以拥有旨在掩盖组织无法或不想解决的问题的扯淡的工作。大卫还描述了第三种扯淡的工作。从表面上看，这些工作并非毫无意义，但一个组织拥有它们的唯一原因是因为其他组织拥有它们。大卫称做这些工作的人为“打手”（Goons）。我问他这个词是什么意思。我不得不编造这个词，因为有太多人
wrote to me with jobs that I hadn't really anticipated. Jobs which involved a certain element of aggression, which might have seen necessary or helpful to the corporation. They weren't completely useless, but that the people doing them felt shouldn't exist anyway, largely because they felt the entire industry or profession was unnecessary So telemarketers were a great example. Hi, Mr. Vitton. I'm calling today with a special offer for you Telemarketers felt strongly that I mean 95% of telemarkers I'm sure feel strongly that if all telemarketers were to vanish in a puff of smoke the world would be a better place But a lot of corporate lawyers feel that way too. I mean, sure, there's some higher ups who would argue, no,
写信给我，告诉他们的工作是我没有真正预料到的。这些工作包含一定程度的攻击性，对公司来说可能是必要的或有帮助的。它们并非完全没用，但从事这些工作的人觉得无论如何都不应该存在，主要是因为他们觉得整个行业或职业都是不必要的，所以电话推销员就是一个很好的例子。嗨，维坦先生。我今天打电话给您，为您提供一个特别优惠。电话推销员强烈地觉得——我的意思是95%的电话推销员肯定强烈地觉得——如果所有的电话推销员都烟消云散了，世界会变得更美好。但很多公司律师也有同感。我的意思是，当然，有些高层会辩称，不，
corporate law is very important, it holds things together. But most corporate lawyers I've talked to, usually lower ranking ones, will say, oh, come on. I mean, if this entire industry were to disappear, it would be great. I mean, you only need a corporate lawyer because somebody else has a corporate lawyer. It's a little like a feudal lawyer. They always say feudal lords are there to protect the
公司法非常重要，它把事情维系在一起。但大多数与我交谈过公司律师，通常是级别较低的律师，会说：得了吧。我的意思是，如果整个行业都消失了，那将是一件好事。我的意思是，你只需要一个公司律师，因为别人也有一个公司律师。这有点像封建律师。他们总是说封建领主是为了保护
peasants. That's their justification for taking feudal rents. But if you really look into the matter, who are they protecting the peasants from? Other feudal lords. So if there were no feudal lords, feudal lords would be unnecessary. So that's why I called them goons. There's an element of aggression there. But on the other hand, they're only there because other such aggressive people exist. David says another BS job is the flunky. These jobs primarily exist to make someone or
农民。那是他们收取封建租金的理由。但如果你深入调查这件事，他们是在保护农民免受谁的伤害？其他封建领主。所以如果没有封建领主，封建领主就是不必要的。这就是为什么我称他们为打手。其中有一种攻击性。但另一方面，他们之所以存在，仅仅是因为其他这样具有攻击性的人存在。大卫说，另一种扯淡的工作是“马屁精”（Flunky）。这些工作主要存在的目的是为了让某人或
something look impressive. Classic flunkies of the past have included things like dormant or footmen. I always wondered what a footman actually was. You always read about them in Allison Wunderland in these 19th century books. You know what a footman worked? They were the guys who were these really fancy military looking uniforms. What the thing they actually did was they ran in front of people's carriages looking for bumps in the road. So a whole idea is if I have a servant just to do this one, basically kind of superfluous, not really totally necessary thing, I'm really rich and important so you should know that. And that's a classic flunky. Often flunkies will be assigned one very minor task,
某事看起来气派。过去典型的马屁精包括门童或随从等。我一直想知道随从实际上是什么。你在《爱丽丝梦游仙境》和这些19世纪的书籍中总能读到他们。你知道随从是做什么的吗？他们就是那些穿着非常花哨的军服的人。他们实际上做的事情是，他们在人们的马车前面奔跑，寻找路上的颠簸。所以整个想法是，如果我有一个仆人只做这一个，基本上有点多余、并非完全必要的事情，我真的很富有、很重要，所以你应该知道这一点。这就是一个典型的马屁精。通常，马屁精会被指派一项非常微不足道的任务，
sort of like the guy who tweezes the lords mustash before a jaust or something like that. But really they're just there so that everybody can know I've got lots of servants. But in the corporate world is very much the same, because in the corporate world, the actual status of an executive is often measured by how many people work on dirt. So he has no incentive to get rid of unnecessary employees. And in fact, you often find people saying, yeah, I'm just there to make someone else look important or seem important. Receptionists often say that. Obviously, some receptionists are very busy and have a real job, but there are some
有点像在比武前用镊子修剪领主的胡须之类的人。但实际上他们只是为了让每个人都知道我有很多仆人。但在公司世界里也是如此，因为在公司世界里，高管的实际地位往往是通过有多少人为他卖力来衡量的。所以他没有动力去解雇不必要的员工。事实上，你经常会发现人们说：是的，我只是为了让别人看起来很重要或显得很重要。接待员经常这么说。很显然，有些接待员非常忙，有一份真正的 工作，但有些接待员，
receptionists who, you know, maybe they get one phone call a day too. Otherwise, they change the candy bowl or, you know, water the plants or something, but basically they're just sitting around. So why do they have receptionists at all? You know, if it's just one call a day, they could just take the call themselves, right? The reason why is because if you don't have a receptionist, you don't look like a real corporation. One reason the companies end up with BS jobs is that it's sometimes difficult or impossible
你知道的，也许他们一天只接一个电话。除此之外，他们换换糖果碗，或者，你知道的，给植物浇水什么的，但基本上他们只是坐在那里。那么为什么还要设接待员呢？你知道的，如果一天只有一个电话，他们自己接电话就行了，对吧？原因是因为如果你没有接待员，你看起来就不像一个真正的公司。公司最终以扯淡的工作告终的一个原因有时是，摆脱那些表现不佳的人很困难、不可能
or unpleasant to get rid of people who are not functioning well. You mentioned the example of the guy who's apologizing for the carpenter not showing up. Now, it could just be that getting rid of that guy and hiring another carpenter might be administratively onerous. So, talk to me about this idea that part of the problem might actually just be
或令人不快。你提到了那个为木匠没出现而道歉的家伙的例子。现在，可能只是因为摆脱那个家伙并雇佣另一个木匠在行政上可能很繁重。所以，跟我谈谈这个想法：部分问题实际上可能只是
rigidity in how organizations work and instead of basically getting rid of the person you don't want and finding the person you do want, you end up sometimes just keeping the person you don't want or now hiring an additional person to come in and do the job that you actually do need to get done. That was one of my favorite examples actually, because I, you know, the taskmasters are obviously the ones that were most difficult to get them to fess off and tell send in testimonies about what's going on, but I got a couple. And one of them said exactly that. One reason that you end up getting so many bullshit jobs in large bureaucracies is if someone has seniority and you know
组织运作方式的僵化，你没有解雇你不想要的人并找到你想要的人，而是有时最终保留了你不需要的人，或者现在雇佣了一个新的人来做你实际需要完成的工作。那实际上是我最喜欢的例子之一，因为我，你知道的，任务主管显然是最难让他们招供并发送关于发生的事情的证词的人，但我得到了几个。其中一个正是这么说的。你最终在大型官僚机构中获得如此多扯淡工作的一个原因是，如果某人有资历，而且你清楚
good reports, well it's almost impossible to fire them. So if suddenly they become a drunk or just you know lose interest in the job, become bad at what they do, the easiest thing to do instead of getting rid of them is to hire someone else to do their job. But if you hire someone else to do their job, you can't admit that they're doing their job, right? So you have to make up a different job. And then often you have to walk them through, get them, you know, tell them what to put on
良好的报告，嗯，几乎不可能解雇他们。因此，如果他们突然变成酒鬼或只是，你知道的，对工作失去兴趣，变得不称职，最简单的事情不是摆脱他们，而是雇佣其他人来做他们的工作。但是如果你雇佣其他人来做他们的工作，你不能承认他们在做他们的工作，对吧？所以你必须编造一份不同的工作。然后你经常必须带他们走过流程，让他们，你知道的，告诉他们把什么写在
their CV so they look like they can do this other thing. Even though really they're going to be doing, you know, what the drunk guy does. And you know, so you have these elaborate rituals of creating dummy jobs. And then, you know, when that guy goes, you might need to hire someone to actually do the made up job. And it just becomes endlessly mocky of alien and elaborate. What we're doing here, Michael handles more of the big picture stuff. And I handle more of the day-to-day stuff. So together, I think I understand.
他们的简历上，这样他们看起来就能做这另一件事。尽管实际上他们要做的是，你知道的，那个酒鬼做的事。你知道的，所以你有这些精心设计的仪式来创造虚假的工作。然后，你知道的，当那个人离开时，你可能需要雇佣某人来实际做这份凭空捏造的工作。这变得无休止地模仿、异化和繁琐。我们在这里所做的是，迈克尔处理更多的大局事情。而我处理更多的日常事情。所以合在一起，我想我明白了。
All right. Each of you is doing half a job. No. Sometimes I can hardly handle that. Yeah. When we come back, the psychological consequences of working in a job that you not only find boring, but that you think is meaningless. I want to talk about the range of psychological effects that you described that arise from
好吧。你们俩每个人都在做半份工作。不。有时我几乎应付不过来。对。当我们回来时，从事一份不仅觉得无聊，而且认为毫无意义的工作所带来的心理后果。我想谈谈你所描述的由
doing these kinds of BS jobs. And I want to begin with research that you cite that was done amongst babies, that you say sort of shows the value of meaningful work. What was the research? Yeah, that was really interesting. I'd heard this expression and I'd always stuck in my head, the pleasure at being a cause. It's always some made sense to me somehow. You know, a lot of what we do, which seems fun, doesn't seem to have any point, but it's just like knowing that you can do things itself is kind of fun. And indeed, there was a German psychologist who was trying to come up with a
从事这些扯淡的工作引起的种种心理影响。我想从你引用的在婴儿身上进行的研究开始，你说这在某种程度上展示了有意义工作的价值。这项研究是什么？是的，那真的很有趣。我听说过这个表达，它一直印在我的脑海里，“作为原因的快乐”。不知何故，这对我来说总是很有意义。你知道的，我们做的很多事情，看起来很有趣，似乎没有任何意义，但只是知道你能做事本身就挺有意思的。事实上，曾有一位德国心理学家试图提出一个
theory of play actually. And he noticed something very interesting. He noticed that infants when they're first trying to figure out who they are. Because at first infants don't even really understand that they are a discrete entity separate from the world around them, where they stop and the world starts is not clear to them. They're kind of continuous, so their mother or their continuous, their environment. Okay, so, so baby actually figure out that they are discreet entity. At the moment, they realize they can have predictable effects on the world. So there's some point where a child say they're moving their arm around and they move something on the table. No, like move a pencil. And they realize if they move their arm the same way, the pencil will move in the same way as well And the moment where they realize that there's this sort of feeling of incredible happiness comes over a troll
关于游戏的理论。他注意到了一件非常有趣的事情。他注意到婴儿在刚开始弄清楚自己是谁时。因为起初婴儿甚至不明白他们是一个独立于周围世界的实体，他们在哪里停止而世界从哪里开始对他们来说并不清楚。他们有点连续的，所以他们的母亲或他们的连续，他们的环境。好吧，所以，婴儿实际上弄清楚了他们是一个独立的实体。在那一刻，他们意识到他们可以对世界产生可预测的影响。所以有某个时刻，比方说一个孩子正在挥舞手臂，他们移动了桌子上的某样东西。不，就像移动一支铅笔。他们意识到如果他们以同样的方式移动手臂，铅笔也会以同样的方式移动，
You can see them just let a absolute joy and delight like Wow, I can move a pencil. This is great. It'll happen the same way every time and and That moment they say is the moment you realize that you are something different from the world. You know, you are a thing that can have effects on the world. And what they argue is that sense of self is tied up with that kind of joyous realization that you can have effects on the world. What happens when small children are prevented from influencing their worlds?
而他们意识到这一点的瞬间，那种难以置信的幸福感涌上了一个孩子的头脑。你可以看到他们流露出绝对的喜悦和快乐，就像：哇，我可以移动铅笔了。这太棒了。每次都会以同样的方式发生，并且他们说，那一刻就是你意识到你与世界有所不同的时刻。你知道的，你是一个能够对世界产生影响的东西。他们的论点是，这种自我意识与那种你能对世界产生影响的快乐认识息息相关。当小孩子被阻止影响他们的世界时，会发生什么？
David says the experience of decline in well-being and efficacy. Kids freak out, you know, they go from being incredibly happy to being really confused and upset. You're blocked from having any meaningful to being really confused and upset. You're blocked from having any meaningful effect on the world around you. You kind of collapse. Now I really think that's what's happening, in the case of bullshit jobs. People suddenly become incredibly depressed.
大卫说，那是幸福感和效能感的下降体验。孩子们抓狂了，你知道的，他们从极其快乐变得非常困惑和沮丧。你被阻止对周围的世界产生任何有意义的——变得非常困惑和沮丧。你被阻止对周围的世界产生任何有意义的影响。你有点崩溃了。现在我真的认为这就是扯淡工作发生的情况。人们突然变得非常沮丧。
They lose all motivation. They don't understand why they feel that way. That's, you know, in a way, they think I should be happy, right, on getting paid money to do nothing. Something for nothing, that's a great deal, but why am I so miserable? I think that's the reason. I remember once talking with Peter Ubel, he's a researcher at Duke University. He once conducted a study. He told volunteers that they could sit silently, no iPhones, no distractions, nothing for five minutes, and if they did that, they would get $2.50.
他们失去了所有的动力。他们不明白为什么他们会有这种感觉。那就是，在某种程度上，他们认为我应该感到高兴，对吧，白拿钱什么都不做。不劳而获，这是一笔巨款，但为什么我这么痛苦？我想这就是原因。我记得有一次和彼得·乌贝尔交谈，他是杜克大学的研究人员。他曾做过一项研究。他告诉志愿者，他们可以静静地坐着，没有iPhone，没有分心，什么都没有，持续五分钟，如果他们这样做，他们将获得2.50美元。
He also told them that they could spend the time solving very, very difficult problems. And he asked them how much would they want to be paid for doing the puzzles instead of doing nothing. Here's what Ubel told me. We found that the large majority of the students said we'd have to pay them more than $2.50 to solve the word puzzles. And yet when we actually finished the five minutes and asked them how much they enjoyed those five minutes, the people solving the word puzzles enjoyed the five minutes and asked them how much they enjoyed those five minutes,
他还告诉他们，他们可以把时间花在解决非常非常困难的问题上。他问他们，如果做拼图而不是什么都不做，他们希望得到多少报酬。乌贝尔是这样告诉我的：“我们发现，绝大多数学生说，我们必须付给他们2.50美元以上，他们才愿意去解字谜。然而，当我们真正完成这五分钟并问他们有多喜欢这五分钟时，那些解字谜的人却很喜欢这五分钟，并问他们有多喜欢这五分钟……”
the people solving the word puzzles enjoyed the five minutes significantly more. And yet very few of them said, yeah, pay me two dollars and I'd be happy to do word puzzles because at least I'll be having fun. One implication from the study, David, is that people don't fully appreciate all the dimensions of a job when they apply for it. So you might think, hey, it's great to get paid money for doing absolutely nothing, but the issue of boredom, the issue of meaninglessness, the issue of pointlessness, these things become salient only after you've started doing the job. So in some ways, are our psychological biases partly to blame for the proliferation of
那些解字谜的人对这五分钟的喜爱程度要显著得多。然而，很少有人会说：“好吧，付我两美元，我很乐意去做字谜，因为至少我会玩得很开心。”大卫，这项研究的一个启示是，人们在申请工作时并没有完全意识到工作的各个维度。所以你可能会想，嘿，拿钱什么都不做感觉真棒，但无聊的问题、毫无意义的问题、毫无价值的问题，这些事情只有在你开始做这份工作之后才会凸显出来。所以在某些方面，我们的心理偏见是不是造成了
BS jobs? Well, I think it's partly to that we're all taught that people want something for nothing. I mean, think about economics. What does economics teach you? Basically, that we all want something for nothing. That, you know, people wish to get the maximum benefit for the least expenditure of time and resources, an effort. So, you know, according to economics, anybody who's handed a job where they're paid good money to do nothing should be happy as a clam, you know.
狗屁工作（BS jobs）泛滥的部分原因？嗯，我认为部分原因在于我们都被灌输了一种观念，即人们想不劳而获。我的意思是，想想经济学。经济学教给你什么？基本上，我们都想不劳而获。你知道，人们希望以最少的时间、资源和精力的付出获得最大的利益。所以，你知道，根据经济学的观点，任何得到一份拿高薪却什么都不用的工作的人都应该高兴得像个蛤蜊一样，你知道的。
But, so, one of the strange things is that people don't understand why they aren't happy. They're we're given this false assumption about what people are basically about and what people are basically like. You you argue that there are even spiritual consequences of BS jobs and one of them is something that you call scriptlessness. What do you mean by that? I remember being very impressed by a psychological study which looked at people, you know, sort of looked at times they'd been in love or people had been in love with them when they were teenagers and how they'd managed to integrate the experience or especially unrequited love. And what they found out was that, you know, if you're in love with someone who does not return your feelings,
但是，奇怪的事情之一是，人们不明白为什么他们不快乐。我们被灌输了关于人们的本质以及人们的基本状况的虚假假设。你认为狗屁工作甚至会产生精神上的后果，其中之一就是你所谓的“无剧本状态”（scriptlessness）。你这是什么意思？我记得有一个心理学研究给我留下了深刻的印象，它观察了人们——比如观察了他们十几岁时恋爱或别人爱上他们的经历，以及他们如何设法整合这种体验，尤其是单恋。他们发现，如果你爱上了一个不回应你感情的人，
well, it's difficult, but you can come up with a story about it. People had come to terms with it. They almost remembered the incidents fondly 20 years later. It was the people who had other people who were in love with them who didn't actually feel the same way about them, who were still kind of hurt. They were really confused.
这虽然很难，但你能编出一个关于它的故事。人们已经接受了它。20年过去了，他们甚至还带着温情回忆起这些事。而那些被别人爱着、但实际上对对方没有同样感觉的人，却仍然感到某种伤害。他们真的很困惑。
They felt guilty, but they felt indignant, and they just didn't know how to feel. And one of the reasons why they suggested is because, you know, if you're in love with someone who doesn't love you, you know exactly how you're supposed to feel. There's like 2,000 years of literature telling you exactly how you're supposed to feel, how you're supposed to behave, what's appropriate, what isn't. Whereas if you're on the other side, you're pretty much at a loss. You know, there are no novels written from the point of view of Roxanne instead of, you know, Sierra-No.
他们感到内疚，但也感到愤怒，只是不知道该作何感想。他们提出的原因之一是，如果你爱上了一个不爱的人，你确切地知道自己应该有什么感受。有两千年的文学作品准确地告诉你应该有什么感受、应该如何行为、什么才是得体的、什么不是。然而，如果你处于另一端，你几乎就会感到不知所措。你知道的，没有小说是从罗克珊（Roxanne）而不是西哈诺（Cyrano）的角度来写的。
And so those people didn't have a script. In a very similar way, it seems like, bullshit, jobs put one in a similar situation. You don't know how you're supposed to feel about this. You should be happy, but you're not. You can't, don't know if you can talk about it. You don't know who you can confer. There's no kind of anchor to give yourself a sense of what's going on
所以这些人没有剧本。以非常相似的方式，狗屁工作似乎把人置于类似的境遇中。你不知道自己对这件事该有什么感觉。你应该快乐，但你并不快乐。你不知道自己是否能谈论它。你不知道可以向谁倾诉。没有任何锚点能让你对正在发生的事情有一个清醒的认识
or what you should think or do about it. One of the most interesting ideas you explore is that in many countries we have a fetish about work. We think a person who's working a job, even if it's a BS job, is in some ways a better human being than the person who's just hanging out. So it seems like there's a moral component to this whole belief structure. Absolutely. I think this cannot be understood, except through looking at the history of, well, for one thing, religion. I mean, if you look at the story of the Garden of Eden, or even Hesiod's story of Prometheus, they both have the same basic theme, which is that, you know, we have to work because we
或者你应该对此有何想法或行动。你探讨的最有趣的想法之一是，在许多国家，我们对工作有一种迷恋。我们认为一个有工作的人，即使是一份狗屁工作，在某种程度上也比那些只是闲晃的人是一个更好的人。所以这整个信仰体系似乎包含着道德成分。绝对是这样。我认为，如果不审视历史，特别是宗教史，就无法理解这一点。我的意思是，如果你看看伊甸园的故事，或者赫西俄德（Hesiod）关于普罗米修斯的故事，它们都有相同的主题，那就是，你知道，我们必须工作是因为我们
disobeyed the gods, or we disobeyed God. We rebelled and we're punished. And God's recedence is creator. So in a way, we are punished. They said, you want to be like God? Fine. Be like God. You can create the world. But it'll be painful and miserable. So there's this notion that a work is productive and b that it is suffering and that it's kind of our punishment for our own arrogance. But at the same time, it's seen as moralizing, you know, through working we become an adult, become a real mature, self-contained, like human being, as opposed to kids who are just all over the place, right?
违背了神意，或者说我们违背了上帝。我们反叛了，受到了惩罚。上帝是创造者。所以在某种程度上，我们受到了惩罚。他们说，你想成为上帝吗？好吧。去当上帝吧。你可以创造世界。但这将是痛苦和悲惨的。所以有这样一种观念：工作是具有生产力的，其次它是一种痛苦，这是我们对自身傲慢的惩罚。但与此同时，它被视为一种道德塑造，你知道，通过工作我们成长为成年人，成为一个真正成熟、独立、完整的人，而不是那些到处乱跑的孩子，对吧？
You know, through working, becoming an adult. So all of these ideas, work as production, work as punishment, work as necessary to retain maturity, all kind of bundled together. And what's happened is that there is this idea now that if you're not doing something, something you don't really enjoy, you're not working harder at it than you really want to be working, preferably for someone you don't like very much, you know, you don't like very much. You're just a bad person. You're not a real adult, certainly, and you're probably just some lazy parasite who doesn't deserve the help or support of their community.
你知道，通过工作成为成年人。所以所有这些想法——工作作为生产、工作作为惩罚、工作作为保持成熟的必要条件——都交织在了一起。而现在发生的情况是，产生了一种观念：如果你没有在做某件事——一件你并不是真的很享受的事，你对它的努力程度没有超过你真正愿意付出的程度，最好还是为了一个你其实不太喜欢的人工作，你就是一个糟糕的人。你绝对算不上一个真正的成年人，你可能只是个懒惰的寄生虫，不配得到社区的帮助或支持。
And that idea has been just drilled into people, like, incisantly, for the last 30, 40 years. Isn't it possible that there are actually jobs that people might find meaningless or pointless, but that are, in fact, useful or essential. I mean, to take your example, it does seem absurd to ask Kurt to drive, you know, a hundred miles to help move a computer 15 feet. But maybe they have found, I'm just tossing this out, when you factor in liability or regulations or some other set of rules, that this is indeed the cheapest way to do something. So isn't it possible that at least in some cases, bullshed jobs have a purpose that might be invisible to the person who's walking the job? Well, it's possible. And no doubt there are a few cases like that.
这种想法在过去30到40年里一直被不间断地灌输给人们。难道有没有可能，确实存在一些人们可能会觉得毫无意义或毫无价值，但实际上却很有用或至关重要的工作？我的意思是，以你的例子来说，要求库尔特（Kurt）开车跑一百英里去帮忙把一台电脑挪动15英尺，这确实显得很荒谬。但也许他们发现——我只是随口说说——当你把责任、规章制度或其他一系列规则考虑进去时，这确实是完成某项事情的最便宜的方式。所以，有没有可能至少在某些情况下，狗屁工作也有着对于身处工作岗位的人来说可能是隐形的目的呢？嗯，这是可能的。毫无疑问，确实存在一些这样的情况。
But I think that the number of cases like that must be far outnumbered by the number of cases where it's the other way around. Because, after all, if there is some way that Kurt's job is really necessary, it seems unlikely that no one's going to explain that to him. On the other hand, if you are working for a magazine that it turns out it doesn't really exist, I had an example like that. A magazine that doesn't exist? Yeah, she was writing for travel magazine.
但我认为这类情况的数量远远少于相反情况的数量。因为毕竟，如果库尔特的工作真的有其必要性，那么似乎不太可能没有人向他解释这一点。另一方面，如果你在一家最终发现根本不存在的杂志社工作——我确实遇到过这样的例子。一本根本不存在的杂志？是的，她曾为一本旅游杂志写稿。
One of those ones, they have an airplanes. And gradually, she figured out that it's a scam. Actually, there is no such magazine. They have this whole office full of people preparing copy and illustrations for a magazine that never is actually printed. Why would they do that? She wasn't quite sure.
那是飞机上能看到的那种杂志。渐渐地，她发现这是一个骗局。实际上根本没有这样一本杂志。他们整个办公室的人都在为一本永远不会真正印刷的杂志准备文稿和插图。他们为什么要这么做？她也不是很确定。
She thought it might have to do a tax write-off or they got a grant or some sort of, there's some financial scam going on. There's lots of things like that going on. So if you're involved in a scam or something like that, of course that's a very thing they won't tell you. So if there is a way that your job seems pointless but it's useful, chances are someone
她认为这可能与核销税款有关，或者他们获得了某种拨款，其中存在某种金融骗局。有很多类似的事情正在发生。因此，如果你卷入了某种骗局之类的事情，这当然是他们绝不会告诉你的一点。所以，如果你的工作看起来毫无意义但实际上有用，那么很有可能有人
is going to explain that to you just because you want your work as to be motivated. On the other hand, if you're writing reports for a central office and the central office just takes the reports and files and never reads them, probably they're not going to tell you that. I want to talk about the idea that jobs in some ways are jobs. They pay the bills, they cover the mortgage, they allow us to go on vacations. I want to play your clip from the movie Dinner with Schmach's where the lead character
会向你解释这一点，因为你希望你的工作是有动力的。另一方面，如果你在为中央办公室写报告，而中央办公室只是把报告拿去存档却从不阅读，他们大概是不会告诉你这一点的。我想谈谈这样一种观点：在某些方面，工作就是工作。它们支付账单，偿还抵押贷款，让我们去度假。我想播放一段电影《饭局私奔》（Dinner for Schmucks）中的片段，其中男主角
explains to his girlfriend why he works at a job that he doesn't love. There's you and the me that you know and we love each other and we have a wonderful life. But then there's the me that you don't know and the me that you don't know has to do things sometimes so that you and the me that you know can live in this nice apartment and eat at nice restaurants and go to Cabo for Christmas. He takes care of us. You know what? There should not be any you. I don't know. But there is. You might not like him. I don't like him. I hate him. But we need him. You know, it's like the CIA. The CIA?
向他的女朋友解释他为什么要做一份并不热爱的工作：“有你，也有你所认识的我，我们彼此相爱，我们过着美好的生活。但还有一个你所不认识的我，那个你所不认识的我有时必须去做一些事情，这样你和那个你所知道的我才能住进这间漂亮的公寓，在好餐厅吃饭，去卡波（Cabo）过圣诞节。他照顾着我们。”“你知道吗？根本不应该有这样一个你。”“我不知道。”“但确实有。”“你可能不喜欢他。”“我不喜欢他。我讨厌他。但我们需要他。你知道，这就像中情局（CIA）。”“中情局？”
Mm-hmm. The CIA does some pretty funky nasty stuff in the shadows, but I for one am glad they're there. What do you think David? If we didn't have BS jobs, how would millions of people get paid? Well, there's a lot of ways you could solve that problem. Probably the easiest one would be just pay everybody and then let them sort out what they do for themselves. Because we have this idea that's drilled into our heads that people want something for nothing, but as I say, they're very fact that people
“嗯哼。中情局在阴暗处做一些非常古怪卑鄙的事情，但我个人很高兴有他们存在。”你觉得呢，大卫？如果我们没有狗屁工作，数百万人的薪水从何而来？嗯，有很多方法可以解决这个问题。可能最简单的方法就是付钱给所有人，然后让他们自己决定用这些钱做什么。因为我们脑子里被灌输了一种观念，认为人们想要不劳而获，但正如我所说，事实上那些
who are actually paid to do nothing are so unhappy, shows that that's not really true. People really do want to have an effect on the world around them. I always give the example of prisons, obviously in America, they basically force people to work, but even where they don't, you know, they have really nice prisons. They use withdrawing your work privileges as a way of punishing you. That is to say, you know, given a choice between sitting around playing cards or watching TV all day and pressing shorts in the prison laundry room, you know, even these mostly rather anti-social people, you know, would actually rather work than just sit around. So people want to work.
拿薪水却什么都不做的人是如此痛苦，这表明事实并非如此。人们确实希望对他们周围的世界产生影响。我总是举监狱的例子。显然在美国，他们基本上强迫人们工作，但即使在不强迫的地方，你知道，他们的监狱条件非常好。他们将剥夺你的工作特权作为一种惩罚方式。也就是说，你知道，在整天坐着打牌、看电视与在监狱洗衣房里压短裤之间进行选择时，你知道，即使是这些大多具有反社会倾向的人，实际上也宁愿工作也不愿只是闲坐着。所以人们是想要工作的。
So I kind of support universal basic income. I've kind of come around to the position that that's probably the best solution. If we just give people, you know, we say like, okay, all this technology, all these robots, you know, it's produced collectively by all of us. It's not like one person came up with that. That's a product of, you know,
所以我某种程度上支持全民基本收入。我逐渐接受了这样的立场，即这可能是最好的解决方案。如果我们只是给人们，你知道的，我们说，好吧，所有这些技术，所有这些机器人，你知道的，这是我们所有人共同创造的。这并不是说某个人想出了这一切。这是……的产物
a center of ancestors doing hundreds of years of thinking and and laboring. So let's pay us all back for that work, you know. Let's give everybody a basic income and leave it up to you to decide what to do. To be sure, a universal basic income is a controversial idea. Also, while it would take care of essential needs, a basic income wouldn't buy people lots of dinners in fine restaurants or vacations in Cabo. David's underlying point though is that instead of aspiring for greater material wealth, we should all seek more leisure time. I know perfectly well that there's lots of societies, most societies where people work
数百年思考和劳动的祖先的结晶。所以让我们为那项工作付给我们所有人报酬，你知道的。让我们给每个人一份基本收入，然后由你自己决定该做什么。可以肯定的是，全民基本收入是一个有争议的想法。而且，虽然它能满足基本需求，但基本收入并不能让人在高级餐厅里享用很多次晚餐，也不能让人去卡波度假。不过，大卫的根本观点是，我们不应该追求更多的物质财富，而应该寻求更多的闲暇时间。我非常清楚，有很多社会——大多数社会——人们的工作
distinctly less than they do today. Probably the average oppressed medieval surf worked about half of what we work. But certainly people in other societies can be found to work two or three hours a day maximum. So what do they do? They come up with incredibly interesting things to do. You know, we'd all be sitting around in cafes, gossiping, and the gossip would get really interesting, you know, because people would have enough time to have lives. We just don't know what it's like to actually have a life anymore, a lot of us. If I didn't have to work and I still have money coming in, I would be in a
明显少于今天。也许平均受压迫的中世纪农奴的工作时间只有我们的一半左右。但可以肯定的是，在其他社会中，人们每天最多工作两三小时。那么他们都在做什么呢？他们想出了令人难以置信的有趣事情来做。你知道，我们都会坐在咖啡馆里闲聊，而且闲聊会变得非常有趣，你知道的，因为人们会有足够的时间去生活。我们中的许多人只是不知道真正拥有生活是什么感觉。如果我不需要工作而且还有源源不断的收入，我就会去
developing country in Africa, helping people learn and participate in the democratic process and get rid of leaders who don't support their interests. I'd love to be in like a cover band. I think that would be a lot of fun. Led Zeppelin, Black Sabbath, you know, those kind of genres. If I didn't have to work, I'd go to Asia. You know, I would ensure that those individuals that have substance use disorder were really
非洲的一个发展中国家，帮助人们学习并参与民主进程，摆脱那些不符合他们利益的领导人。我很乐意加入一个翻唱乐队。我认为那会很有趣。齐柏林飞船（Led Zeppelin）、黑色安息日（Black Sabbath），你知道，那种流派。如果我不需要工作，我会去亚洲。你知道，我会确保那些患有物质使用障碍（substance use disorder）的个人真正得到
taken care of on an equitable level. I mean, I like to go to the space. The space? Yeah. If I have money, I know if I can do anything. I love to see the London School of Economics. He studies theories of value and social constructs. He is the author of the book, Bullshit Jobs.
公平水平的照顾。我的意思是，我喜欢去太空。太空？是的。如果我有钱，我知道我能做任何事。我喜欢去伦敦政治经济学院（London School of Economics）。他研究价值理论和社会结构。他是《狗屁工作》一书的作者。
David, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a real pleasure. This week's episode was produced by Aditya Bound Labudi with help from Parth Shah and Laura Koural. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen and Thomas Liu. Special thanks to Dan Charles. Our run song here of this week is Samuel Alwin Mosley, a producer at the BBC. There are
大卫，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。这真是个荣幸。本周的节目由阿迪亚·鲍恩·拉布迪（Aditya Bound Labudi）制作，帕特·沙阿（Parth Shah）和劳拉·库拉尔（Laura Koural）提供了帮助。节目由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）剪辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）。特别感谢丹·查尔斯（Dan Charles）。我们本周的主题曲作者是BBC制作人塞缪尔·奥尔温·莫斯利（Samuel Alwin Mosley）。有
lots of logistical details that go into coordinating an interview, particularly when a guest is overseas. David Graber was in London when we spoke with him, and Samuel took care of all those little details to make sure the conversation went smoothly. Thank you, Samuel. If you've escaped from a bullshit job and have advice for listeners in a similar situation, share your story with us on social media, either by tagging us in the post or with a hashtag you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
许多后勤细节需要协调来安排一次采访，特别是当嘉宾在海外时。大卫·格雷伯（David Graber）在我们与他交谈时身在伦敦，塞缪尔处理了所有这些小细节，以确保对话顺利进行。谢谢你，塞缪尔。如果你已经摆脱了狗屁工作，并对处于类似情况的听众有什么建议，请在社交媒体上与我们分享你的故事，或者在帖子中标记我们，或者带上话题标签。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。